hundreds of thousands of young
immigrants are resting a bit
easier this morning after the supreme
court issued a ruling that allows the
so-called
dreamers to stay in the u.s the high
court
rejected the trump administration's
attempt to end the daca program
it protects about 650 000 undocumented
immigrants
brought to the u.s as children from
deportation
jan crawford is at the supreme court jan
good morning
well it has been a rough week for the
president here at this newly
conservative
supreme court two major losses yesterday
on one of the key issues immigration
that he built his whole campaign around
the 5-4 decision was written by the
conservative chief justice john roberts
joined by the court's four
liberal justices and it said the trump
administration's decision to rescind
the obama-era program was quote
arbitrary and capricious
and it failed to consider the hardship
to daca residents
for the dissenters justice clarence
thomas he called the ruling
an effort to avoid a politically
controversial
but legally correct decision it comes on
the heels of monday's
landmark decision in that transgender
and gay rights case and
yesterday on twitter president trump
lashed out he called the decisions
horrible and politically charged and he
quickly pivoted to november
saying we need more justices vote trump
2020. now the ruling sends the case back
to the department of homeland security
to try again to justify
why it should end this program that is
unlikely to happen
before november which puts the issue of
immigration
the makeup of the supreme court squarely
in
the november election tony
yeah it sure does jim crawford for us
jen thank you very much